ああああああ
par
me
[音楽]
股間を使うことが想像力を磨き
強い思い出として残り続けます
山に行き彼はに行きある遊ぶ
そして目で見てものに触れ
香りを嗅ぎ
風を感じ空気を感じん
あの頃の厚
カバーの水の冷たさ
転んだときの井笠思い出しませんか
森川海
自然の空間にいることで私たちは心が癒され健康を取り戻します
そして日本にはツキがあります
夏の
春のう
お花6そして夏の花火
紅葉そして雪景色
波の音です
河野せずべくです
そしてそこに
鳥たち
そしてさらにそこにアコースティックギターの音色
[音楽]
音がどんどん重なっていくことで
想像力が豊かになり私たちの心はどんどんと癒されていきます
音のない世界です
空気が一気に重たくなり
不安ストレス緊張感が会場に走ります
い
この花火の音んちょっと皆さん思わず叫びたくなりませんか
そうですこの言葉です皆さん是非一緒に叫んでみましょうてなどをつけていただいても
いいと思うんですけど言いますよ
次に打ち上がりますよ
いきますはいみなさん一緒に星のパーマ屋
玄間にありがとうございます
[音楽]
何か飛んできましたよちょっとこの頭聞くと思わず手でを受けたくなったり体をこう腹
痛くなったですね
避けたくなったりしませんか
刺されちゃいます
波の音です
まずまた心が癒されておきます
それではこちらはどうでしょうか
ん
同じ音ですよ同じ水本です
確かにスッキリしますがちょっと嫌ですよね
同じ水の音でもこんなに感じ方が違うのです
[音楽]
誰ですか
すいません確かに健康な商法と言いますがみなさんこの音に紛れて本当にしてしまっ
たらダメですよ
だっ誰ですかあっダメですよ
梅干しです
私たちは梅干しを見ると酸っぱいということを知っています
思わず梅干しを見ていると口の中に唾鬼
唾とか第一が出てきますよね
今ですね皆様の
ギフトバッグの中に実は8ですね
この透明なですね袋に入った本物の梅干しが入っているんです
本物を見るともっと
ツバ
が出ますのでちょっとお好きな方だけはお好きな方はぜひ一緒に食べてみましょう
もう食べちゃった方もいますか
その透明なですね袋に
好きな方だけぜひ
こちら望ましい
この透明性
開けていただいて
ぜひ一緒に食べてみましょうかね
お好きな方だけでいいですよはい
ちょっとくらいので探せないかもしれませんがはい
酸っぱいですね
確かに無星の味です
ありがとうございます
あとでぜひ
麺を食べてみてください
ちょっと酸っぱいですねはい
今度は
皆さんにお配りしたこちらの袋です
開けちゃダメですよというこちらの二ことですね
こちらの袋にはある香りが入っています皆さんでぜひこの香りを当ててみましょう
あのおならの音ではありませんので安心してください
こちらジップでですねこうなっていますのでこちらを鼻につけて
ぜひ開けて変えてみましょう
当てていますよいいですか
の入っ
とても爽やかで
嬉しいな香りがします
じゃあ何でしょうか
正解は
オレンジです
オレンジはとてもフレッシュで爽やかな香りがします
そしてオレンジは私たちをとても前向きに元気にさせてくれます
私たちは香りからもそれが何なのかを当てることができるのです
そして次は皆さん目を閉じて
椅子を触ってみてください
硬さ
柔らかさそして木の素材
鉄の素材
私たちは目を閉じても触れることでそれがどんな素材なんかを当てることができるの
です
私たちは素晴らしい能力があります
そしてこの世の中の中に五感の集大成があります
なんだと思いますか
お弁当なんです
お弁当開けた時の笑顔
作る人は様々なエッセンスを入れます
いろんな形素材の器
そして美味しい
そして香り豊かで大好きなおかず
色の美しい盛り付け
食べる人が笑顔になるように作る人がさまざまなエッセイつを入れます
作る人も様々なエッセイすによってお弁当開けた時の笑顔は
無限に変化します
五感がフルに働くとき人は笑顔になるんです
だから私は空間に互換という要素を取り入れたのです
それでは最近私がやった
五感のを取り入れた作品を少しご紹介します
こちらは今年の夏に
ハワイをテーマとした
ビフィレストランの空間演出を担当しました
よりハワイを感じていただけるようにこちらをハワイの1日の朝昼夜を
時間帯で映像や光そして音楽でハワイの一日を
空間外出しました
そして
this の食事のメニューの方もコンセプトに合わせた美しい彩りの色にもこだわり
盛り付けにもこだわりました
そして
みてください子どもたちのかわいい笑顔です
この仕事は本当に行って良かったお仕事の一つです
そして今年の春に
ホテルの建物全体を使ったプロジェクションマッピングを担当しました
違っています
こちらは桜が満開となるかホテルもリニューアルのお祝いをした
演出です
[音楽]
後ろに見えるのは東京タワーです
一夜限りでしたが本当に拡散のお客様にお花見の気分を楽しんでいただきます
[音楽]
そして今年の靴の秋になる頃に
こちらはお月見をテーマにした空間を作りました
こちらの月のまあるいオブジェは本当の月の写真が貼ってあるんです
まさに月のミニチュアなんです
この空間に音楽と
お酒そしてを単語を食べながらお付きのお月見の気分を楽しんでいただきました
そしてこちらの着物のの方もレンタルで借りれるんです
着物を着て
月と一緒に写真を撮るそうすると皆さん笑顔になります
ここでもお客様に笑顔と思い出を持ち帰っていただきました
それでは僕がなぜ笑顔にこだわるのか
僕は小さい頃とても貧乏でそのせいでいじめられていました
父が体の講師
会社のリストラにあいました
母は3人の子供を一生懸命育ててくれました
友達の
お誕生日に行くとイチゴののったケーキが出てきて
僕の誕生日会はお庭で採れたジャガイモがケーキの代わりでした
とても学校で馬鹿にされていじめられたことを
思い出します
そして
笑っと思いでがあまりないのです
思い出せないのです
僕の唯一
楽しい思い出は友達と遊ぶよりも家で見ているテレビが唯一
僕の楽しい時間でした
そしてテレビから流れる音楽に
僕はすごく子供の頃の僕は心が癒されました
そして音楽が好きになった僕は中学校の時に吹奏楽部に入りました
友達と一緒に奏でる音楽に本当に心がワクワク
しました
そこに来ているお客様の拍手木とても感動を覚え
今でもしっかりと覚えています
そして
学校で
親戚のお兄ちゃんからもらったギターである作曲のコンクールに応募しました
それは
小さい頃子供で障害を持つ子どもたちがう
子どもたちがつけるし2曲をつけるものでした
僕が選んで氏は
小さい頃からあることができない少年の詩
明日の夢というタイトルでした
その子がすごく親にも迷惑かけてネガティブなう
とてもちょっと自分をご前向きできない曲
あの子だったのですがう
曲の最後にそれでも明日を夢見る私です
その歌手に僕はその少年が明るく希望が持てる
元気になる曲を作曲して応募したんです
そしたらそれが
入選しました
僕はステージの上で
その少年の横で歌いました
すると少年は
リズムの楽しいリズムに合わせて
手をたたいて
最高の笑顔を見せてくれたのです
そしてその子の両親も本当にありがとーとー
本当に感謝をされて笑顔になりました
その時初めて知りました
当たり前のことなのですが
誰かを笑顔にするということはその周りの人たちも笑顔にすることを
僕はその時その時から笑顔にこだわったんです
だからもっと
笑顔な人を
笑顔を作る
そして
もっとたくさんの枝をの人達を
そしてもっとたくさんの想い出を作る
僕はそういう仕事を
言うんです
もっとたくさんの映画を作りたいと思うようになりました
皆さんは
この仕事を絶対やりたいと
心から
何か困難な仕事にチャレンジをしたことがありますか
私は
と
クリスマスの時に憧れの表参道ヒルズに娘を連れて
クリスパスを見に行きました
パパきれいパパ写真撮って
いつかここやれたらいいよね
私は
他のデザイナーの方の作品の前で笑顔の娘の写真を
とりました
もう
わかりますよね
私はここいつか絶対やりたいと
そう思って思い続けて4年昨年
コンペに参加してみないかというお話を
いただきました
もう私はもう全力で自分の大きさですけど人生をかけて取り組みました
すると
願いが叶ったのです
思うは招く
テックス札幌のスピーカーさんもおっしゃっていました
この写真をどんな思いで撮ったか
本当に
夢のようで信じられなくて
思わず枝を超えて
この表情になってしまいました
私は自分の作った作品で皆さんを笑顔にして思い出を持ち帰っていただく
そんな仕事が出来ました
そしてこの
イルミネーションは動画でも撮っているのですが
が皆さんちょっと是非観ていただいてもよろしいでしょうか
[音楽]
[拍手]
テーマは一人一人が星のように輝くクリスマスがテーマとして放送しません
[音楽]
ありがとうございます
[拍手]
そしてここには娘だけではなくて
母親も田舎から連れてきたんです
母の笑顔です
ずっと苦労をかけた母がに本当に親効果ができた瞬間でした
今年ももうすぐ
クリスマスです今日は最後に皆様に
特別なスペシャルな演出を用意しました
これは私から皆様へのクリスマスプレゼントです
意義があった
[音楽]
その笑顔です
あなたの笑顔です
あなたのようです
ありがとうございました
[音楽]
[拍手]